welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss an avatar of the way of water is
now working its magic on audiences
testing how long we can be flooded with
water imagery without a bathroom break
but hot damn that old Jimmy Cameron did
it again dazzling us with Gorgeous
visual spectacle and just the right
amount of curiosity about this world of
Pandora and Beyond specifically The
Mystery of the character Kiri voiced by
Sigourney Weaver the teenage daughter of
the biologically engineered Avatar of Dr
Grace Augustine who died in the 2009
film an avatar that had miraculously
become pregnant while in stasis the film
asks but does not answer who is kiri's
Father speculating Norm Spellman from
his Avatar form But ultimately arriving
at an implied Immaculate Conception a
daughter of Ewa scenario but how does it
work and what does it mean exactly well
in this video I'm going to explain
kiri's parentage who is your daddy and
what does he do in the deeper secrets of
this genealogy to Avatar's future and
its past seriously I think I might have
figured out Jimmy's master plan for this
franchise whether it ends in a third
film of film or Never So as avatar The
Wave water begins jigsuli introduces his
teenage adopted daughter Kiri while
talking about natiri's prayer beads as
she sings to AWA he says a bead when we
adopted a daughter Kiri born of Grace's
Avatar a daughter whose conception was a
total mystery so early in the film The
Kids visit the lab and Allelujah
mountains Kiri sits on Grace's Avatar's
cryo chamber where the savitar rests
supposedly brain dead after Grace died
from a gunshot wound and failed to
transfer her Consciousness to the Avatar
but where did Grace really go in that
moment because her final words to Jake
were
I'm with
her she's real
suggesting that Grace became one with
AWA in that moment but again what is AWA
actually is awo really a god in this
universe or something more specific well
is Kiri Marvels at her sleeping mother
they play a video log of Grace right
before she died Grace says maybe I'm
just losing it out here but I'm seeing
real evidence of a systemic response on
a global level I can't I won't use the
term intelligence it's a really
awareness it's a better word it's like
the entire biosphere of Pandora is aware
and capable of this cognitive response I
can't say more of them crucify me
intelligence versus awareness crucify
key terms that help us decode this
mystery but the kids speculate on this
question on behalf of the audience
saying so who do you think knocked her
up I'm pretty sure it was Norm yeah
totally carry response you do not
deserve to live the boys say oh come on
think about it he's a teacher's pet he's
at the lab with her all the time Curie
says I would kill myself I would drink
acid which yikes sorry Norm I mean he's
not that bad of an option but the
brothers look at Norm in the video ugly
and Grace and say hey you're right he's
in every shot look he's giving her the
looks so I'm thinking their two avatars
go off in the woods all alone but then
spider ends of speculation guys
sometimes it's not too good to know who
your father is so throughout the movie
Kiri has more of a connection with the
natural world than the others She lays
in a meadow with a breeze flowing
through the grass matching her breathing
and her heartbeat as these little AWA
float down upon her the other members of
the Sully family struggle to adapt to
the Met kaina Reef but Kiri takes to it
naturally she seemingly never has to
come up for her breath then in the
moment where Reya brings them to the
underwater Spirit tree of the metcaina
during the eclipse and carry bonds with
the stems she's transported to a realm
where she talks to the spirit of her
mother's human form Sigourney Weaver as
Grace she says my beautiful daughter I'm
so happy to see you or are you troubled
and Kiri burst into tears and Grace
Comforts her shh my sweet sweet girl
it'll be okay what is it baby and Carrie
asks the core questions we're all
wondering about why am I different what
does the great mother want from me who
is my father and before Grace could
answer she doubles over in pain and gets
pulled back into a Dark Void and Kyrie
suffers a seizure in the third Act of
the film Curie becomes a guardian angel
using the glowing sea creatures angel
wings and using a trail of glowing A1
and light the path through the sunken
wailing ship for her family to Escape
back to the surface and obviously Kiri
has a very important role to play in the
future films and a much stronger Union
with AWA than any other character in
earlier scene she tells Jake I hear her
heartbeat she's so close so what does
her heartbeat sound like
Mighty now if Avatar the way of water
has taught me one thing is that it'd be
pretty nice to be able to live
underwater it seems quieter floatier and
more full of alien fish I guess this is
underwater you know if you live on
Pandora not like we have oceans on our
own Planet but you know as an added
bonus my skin would always be perfectly
moisturized but you know while I'm out
here living life on land I gotta use
geology to keep my skin healthy and
awesome geology is a 15-time
award-winning personalized skin care
company recognized in hypebeast birdie
Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and they've recently expanded to
offer products for pretty much whatever
you need all you got to do is take their
quick 30 second diagnostic quiz in
geology figures out your routine for you
you need Hair Care well use geology's
co-wash especially formulated cream
cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
or harsh ingredients of typical shampoo
and for the rest of your shower routine
you can use their body washes they're
free of harsh ingredients they smell
great and are refillable and for after
the shower protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin C
plus e feralic serum to keep your skin
looking young and healthy and then a bit
of dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant that quite honestly smells
great right now for a limited time
geology is hooking up our audience with
an absolutely insane offer if you use
the code new rockstars they will give
you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skin care trial set that
discount applies whether you're stocking
up for yourself or stuffing someone
else's stocking instead either way
geology is a cover check out their
awesome gift sets featuring all of your
favorite geology products to get started
just click the link in the description
take the 30 second diagnostic ways in
their team of dermatologists will design
a personalized routine just for you that
ships direct to your door and yeah it
was super weird for James Cameron to
cast Sigourney Weaver to voice a
teenager rather than bringing a younger
actor for the role but it definitely has
a master plan behind this as Weaver
indicated in an interview with
comicbook.com it's Brandon Davis with
just the idea
and you know Jim is crazy enough to cast
me as a 14 year old and as he said that
day and several times afterward this is
your natural age you are 14 you are that
immature I don't think he was as worried
as I was when I he told me I was like
all right how am I going to do this but
luckily I had plenty of time to figure
out not only how to do it but how I
wanted to do it which was not imitating
a 14 year old but really finding
unearthing my for my unhappy 14 year old
in some ways so I think it's obvious
that kiri's father is not Norm but
rather there is no father Kiri is a
child of AWA immaculately conceived like
Anakin Skywalker was by the force but
what is less obvious is who Ewa is or
what it is well James Cameron got the
name AWA as a reversal of Yahweh the
Hebrew name for God we also know that
Ewa did not originate from Pandora and
that the navi associate Three Laws with
awas you shall not set stone upon Stone
neither shall you use the Turning wheel
nor use the medals of the ground in this
film Pandora is no longer a mining
Colony for the unobtaining medal but a
new resource extracted from the whales
Amrita which stops human aging now
actually Amrita is a Sanskrit word
meaning nectar for immortality and in
real world Yoga practices America is
considered to be produced by the human
body once the flow of Kundalini through
the central Channel becomes strong I
know I know James Cameron has us all
watched in his movies and 3D glasses
doing the child's pose but there is a
real Theory among biologists that all of
reproduction is actually a mere
mechanism for our genes to replicate
themselves which really takes the us out
of the equation doesn't it are all of us
just flesh puppets for jeans well if you
look at the world of Avatar that way AWA
could be a natural sentient algorithm
that uses living beings as replicable
nodes as part of its wider agenda it was
simply could have just decided Grace's
Avatar is now pregnant when that Avatar
was plugged into the Tree of Souls at
the moment of Grace's death so I think
the question is not who was kiri's
father it's really who will be curious
children perhaps even her children with
spider so I think AWA could be the
creation of or maybe even the actual
hive mind of advanced future descendants
of kiri's bloodline a new race of
avatars which are already Navi human
hybrids when you think about it Ewa in
the distant future using the spiritual
Force to communicate through time
through the plants of these trees and
through these little Ewa spores to save
these present day races from their own
destruction Grace was the sacrificial
mother crucified so that this Destiny
could unfold the way it needs to that's
why it's not much of an Intel
intelligence it's really more of an
awareness of the knowledge that has
always been there the three laws of the
AWA are to warn against unnatural
technological advancement extracted and
Rita is the poison that stops a race
from dying naturally and returning their
borrowed energy Back To Nature so AWOL
represents the white blood cells of this
biological hive mind helping the body
fight off a viral infection of an
industrialized invasive race of humans
who would never age and forever consume
consume consume which isn't good for the
navi or for humankind so I think James
Cameron just cast Sigourney Weaver to
voice a future matriarch to a hybrid
race that will one day create a Time
independent awareness so that
present-day humans can be more okay with
dying one life ends another begins Let
me know your thoughts on all this and
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at a boss follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you